and logical tradition of AI and and upon
all these scenes personally in this
research including problem sick
programming which I just touched upon
interest with collaborators here at
Berkeley the blog language has done some
very interesting applications on it and
so looking forward to this talk so thank
you very much for starting us off with
this George thank you Dad
okay so I'd like to begin by thanking
all of the students and collaborators
who worked on this particularly Brian
Milch and his PhD thesis was the basis
for a lot of what I'm going to talk
about so I'm gonna give a perspective
from the point of view of the AI
community of how logic and power ability
came together peter Cheeseman the
audience knows a lot about these things
having been one of the protagonists
there's of course other histories in the
logic community itself in philosophy so
AI got going in in the 50s and they
looked at the real world and they said
okay we need to build intelligent
systems for this real world what do we
know about the real world well one thing
we know about the real world it has
things in it that's a very important
observation about the real life doesn't
have to be that way we could we could
live in a very much a sort of a
continuous fluid with no distinguishable
objects whatsoever but we don't there
are things in our world and it's very
helpful to think about them and that
naturally leads you to first-order logic
which is sort of the mathematics of
things in relations among things and
this was the the first proposed formal
basis for AI in the hands of McCarthy
and others in the late 50s and so there
were some very good reasons for doing
this it wasn't that this was the only
possible choice they really had no clue
about how to do AI you know there were
there were people coming from
information theory backgrounds since his
Dix backgrounds linguistics backgrounds
some people thought grammars would be
the basis for AI some people thought
that linear regression and mixtures of
gaussians would be the basis for AI
but logic provides a declarative
substrate so it means that you can you
can express knowledge independent of its
procedural use and then find ways to
combine it for all kinds of new tasks
you can learn it from all kinds of
sources from observational communication
and first order logic is sufficiently
expressive to support pretty much
everything that we need for general
purpose intelligence at least that was
the view
at that time and expressiveness allows
for conciseness and this is absolutely
essential if we're going to learn our
knowledge from from experience so let me
just give you an example the rules of
chess which is a very very very tiny
part of the real world and very very
simple compared to a lot of real world
theories and there's only 32 objects and
64 locations and about a hundred time
steps and if you try to write that using
automata it comes out to this many about
10 to the 38th pages to write down the
rules of chess and you're basically
describing the entire state of the chess
board as a single atomic object and then
you're writing a transition matrix among
these if you want to use something much
more sophisticated register machines or
circuit representations in propositional
logic it's about a hundred thousand
pages and you have proposition symbols
like the white King is on square c4 it
moved twelve or one word right with no
internal structure okay and then you
have to write you know definitions of
checkmate in terms of these proposition
symbols that's extremely difficult and
in first order logic it's about a page
about about as long as it takes to write
the rules in English and in particular
you get to pull you get separate
predicates and arguments you get to
quantify over those arguments and so on
and and this gives you the expressive
power that you need to do lots of
real-world stuff so good and this kept
going until around 1980 and people did
build real robots running using first
order logic theorem provers or
specialized versions of that but they
found an obvious problem they found this
with robots they found this with medical
diagnosis that they don't have the
knowledge required to reach any
conclusions whatsoever in most
real-world situations and that's because
of uncertainty so there's uncertainty in
your state you don't know what state of
the world you're in because you have
partial access to the state with noisy
sensors there's uncertainty about the
physics of the world so you can't
predict with any certainty that a plan
will succeed and so on so we have what
sometimes called modern AI where the
canonical tool has been until deep
learning took over probabilistic
graphical models so I'm going to give
you for those of you who are not
familiar with those a quick background
on a particular flavor of probabilistic
graphical models called Bayesian
networks so a Bayesian network is a way
of defining probability distributions
and the the the sample space for
Bayesian networks is exactly the same as
that for propositional logic so if I
have three boolean variables has there
been a burglary in my house has it been
an earthquake and is the alarm ringing
in my house all right those are three
boolean variables and they relate to
each other in a certain way either of
those two things can cause my alarm to
sound then I can write a distribution
and the topology of the network
expresses conditional independence
relationships that hold and those
conditional independence relationships
imply that the Joint Distribution over
all possible worlds is written as a
product of conditional distributions so
the probability of the burglary
earthquake and alarm variables taking on
particular values is the product of the
probability of burglary happening the
probability of earthquake happening and
then the probability of alarm given
burglary an earthquake so if I put some
numbers in so point zero three of åberg
probability of the burglary 0.02 of an
earthquake and then in the conditional
table for example the point nine power
ability that my alarm sounds if there is
a burglary and an earthquake then the
joint probability can be calculated
looking like that and you'll see that
this is the possible worlds here are
just exactly the possible worlds of the
propositional theory okay so
so Bayesian networks are a propositional
language and in that sense they don't
have things in it right there is no
things for the Bayesian network to refer
to or quantify over so they don't work
that well in the real world in terms of
expressive power although they handle
uncertainty okay so back to the history
what do you think happened next
well the first order logic people
realized that the world is uncertain and
the probabilistic graphical models
people realize that the world has things
in it and that leads you to some kind of
combination and there's this phrase
which I'll explain in a second a new
dawn for AI where we put first order
logic and probability theory together to
get languages that handle uncertainty
and have sufficient expressive power to
do AI and there was a so that phrase
actually comes from this story there was
a cover of a New Scientist the
intelligence revolution and the story
itself is AI algorithm a new dawn for AI
and it says at last something else that
thinks like us ok that's complete
rubbish don't across it the point the
point was that perhaps you might be able
to get something that that looks like
human cognition because it has the
symbolic capabilities of first or logic
and the ability to handle uncertainty
learn from data to connect up to all the
work in statistics and so on so this
idea actually goes back much earlier
than 2011 in the early 90s
people like Jack Breece developed simple
ways to combine first-order expressive
power with with Bayesian networks and
essentially you just you put in logical
variables and function symbols and you
allow quantification over those logical
variables so so this says not is there a
burglary in my house is there an alarm
in my house but for every house this is
the structure of the dependency
relationships among the variables so
house here is couldn't
be viewed as a universally quantified
logical variable region here would be a
function symbol so is there an
earthquake in the region of the house
and so on so you could then take this
which you can think of as a as a
template and you can combine it with
facts about which houses there are and
which regions each of those houses is in
so here's two regions a and B with
houses one on two and region a house is
three four five and region B so you
basically take that set of facts with
this relational template and you combine
those and you can then produce a ground
Bayesian network of the traditional kind
which in fact in this case splits into
two independent networks one for each
region and then you can do inference in
the usual way so you can supply evidence
so some alarms going off in in house one
that's our house the alarm is green so
that's house two three and four and not
in one five and because both alarms and
earthquakes are quite rare but the
earthquake variable couples all the
houses in the given region the fact that
there are two alarms in region B
actually will give you an explanation
saying that the earthquake is much more
likely than a burglary in region B in
region B and so some sense you've built
an earthquake detector just by that
simple three line program okay so so
that's good so we could have saved
ourselves a lot of grief by just
realizing that the world is uncertain
and it has things in it back in 1958 and
we could probably have figured out
something like this
however that's not the only thing that
happens in fact there's an interaction
between uncertainty and things which is
that you don't know what they are and so
the language that I just described
doesn't allow for uncertainty over what
things there are but in fact that's
inevitable when you look at real-world
applications so for example if you're an
insurance company you may not know what
earthquake lesions there are all right
you know what houses there are but you
don't know where
the earthquake regions are you don't
know how they couple the houses together
okay if you're looking at citation data
you don't know initially what papers
exist you just have a whole bunch of
citations you don't know what authors
exist you don't know which venues exist
if you're doing natural language
understanding before you open the book
do you know who the characters are you
know all the locations know before you
open your eyes do you know what objects
you're gonna see no so uncertainty about
the existence of objects and about the
identity of objects is central to almost
all real world applications that require
first-order expressive power so so one
way of thinking about what's going on is
that the languages that we looked at
where you take Bayes nets and you
combine it with logical variables and
quantifiers and function symbols was
only taking advantage of part of
first-order logic and we might call
these closed universe languages because
they assumed effectively the unique
named assumption and domain closure so
unique names means that that every
object in the model structure has a
unique term that refers to it in the
syntax in the language domain closure
means there are no objects in the world
in the model structures except for those
that are named by terms in the language
and this is the core semantics for logic
programming for a database system some
sometimes called Herbrand semantics and
many languages were developed building
on top of logic programming on top of
description logics and so on that that
effectively had this closed universe
semantics so open universe semantics
gets rid of unique names in domain
closure and that is the standard
semantics for first-order logic and so
the blog language we started in 2000
while we started around 2001 but the
blog language itself was published in
2005 and the whole tradition of horrible
istic programming languages which got
going with a paper from : McCullough
MacAlister Pfeffer in 97 and then
sarah's eyeball language in 2001 and is
now a whole community to itself takes on
some of the same ideas and i will
explain the differences between blog and
and the typical horrible istic
programming language later on but let me
give you a little test just to make sure
you've understood this distinction
between closed and open universe so if i
say that bill as a father of William and
Bill as a father of jr. and then I asked
how many children does Bill have one at
least 1 yeah so it depends who you ask
right if you ask Dan who's obviously a
closed universe kind of guy he says yeah
so in close universe semantics the
answer is 2 so this is what a typical
database system will tell you if you say
count as a number of children of their
little say - if you ask first order
logic the answer is somewhere between 1
and infinity right because obviously
William and jr. could be the same person
there could be other children that we
didn't mention and my point is that for
a lot of real-world applications we need
the second kind of semantics because
because of this uncertainty about what
exists so in pictures the possible
worlds could look like this so if you
have if you have closed universe
semantics and we say that there are two
symbols in the language a and B and one
relation then there are exactly 16
possible worlds and they all have a and
B so these are the worlds this is
Vincent Eckland so they all have two
objects a and B that are distinct and
the symbol a always refers to a and
symbol B always refer to B and the only
thing that changes is the relation so
here the relation is empty here a is
related to itself here B is related to
itself here hey it's related to be in
here everything's going to do everything
so so it's nice this is homogeneous it's
often finite
and it's relatively easy to specify
distributions over this set of possible
worlds this is the open universe case so
a and B can refer to the same object or
they can refer to distinct objects there
can be lots of objects that aren't named
by a or B and so you have an unbounded
set of world and it's much more
heterogeneous and so the question is how
do you get to define probabilities on
this more complicated set of possible
worlds so that's the task and the idea
for how to do that actually comes from a
way of thinking about Bayesian networks
as as little machines that construct
possible worlds ok so if I take this
Bayesian network and I just simulate it
so I pick up a value for burglary let's
say it comes out to be true I pick a
value for earthquake comes out to be
false pick a value for alarm it comes
out to be true I've constructed a
possible world just by simulating this
as a little stochastic machine ok so if
I want to make worlds with varying
numbers of objects then it seems like
what I need is a stochastic machine that
cannot only set the values variables but
can actually add objects to the world ok
and so some of the steps when you
simulate the machine a stochastic
machine that's represented by the
program will be steps that add objects
to the world so that's the basic concept
it's really quite simple
so we have two kinds of steps we have
the regular steps which set the values
of variables you have a question
and if everything closed and then open
universe but it seems like closed
universe is just just marginal
distributions
okay so in in the open universe version
right there there will be for example we
are getting alarm signals but we're not
sure which houses they're coming from
we're not sure how many houses there are
and we don't know what geological
regions exist okay so if you
marginalized out all that uncertainty
you would end up with a giant mess every
you would have to have a lot of
indicator variables and everything would
be completely connected so so it it's
it's important to if you want to have a
concise representation of the main right
it's important just inspect effectively
what you're doing is your margin
marginalizing out all the objects
when you marginalize out everything else
right but if you if you if you
marginalize out the objects about whose
existence you are uncertain then you
you're down to a propositional language
in a propositional language where
everything is completely connected and
so that you have no conditional
independence and you can't even write
down what the model should be we can
talk more but if you go to an example we
will see them okay all right so in the
language we have just as with the
quantified Bayes Nets we have ways of
writing these quantified dependencies
among variables so again think of H is
being universally called it so for every
house whether or not the alarm sounds in
a house depends according to some
conditional probability table on whether
there's a burglary in the house and
whether there's an earthquake in the
geological region of the house okay so
that part covers the the closed universe
languages and then in order to to have a
mechanism for adding objects to the
world then we have what are called
number statements so here we'll say that
in some sense the the geological regions
just they just exist and there's
somewhere between 1 and 10 of them and
then the houses exist in regions so the
number of house houses in a given region
is let's say pass on with a mean of 50
and I just want to give you a little
piece of terminology that this this
function here region the region of a
house we'll call it the origin function
because in some sense we think of we
think of this as how the house comes
into being it comes into being because
there's a region in which the houses get
put
okay so the semantics of the language
can be built up in a fairly standard way
the key difference that we'll see is
that the the objects in the model
structures are not just tokens they're
not atoms but they are descriptions of
the generation history of that object
okay and that turns out to be quite
important so I has a type logic so
everything has a type so we have an
object in the model structure called a
geological fault region they have no
origin they just their sewage interest
if you like so the the origin is blank
and this is the third geological fault
region then we have houses so we have a
house whose region is geological fault
region number three and it's the 97th
house in that region okay so those are
those are the objects in the model
structures they are essentially
generation histories and then a random
variable is constructed by taking one of
the predicates or function symbols in
this case is there an earthquake and
then essentially for every possible
tuple of arguments of the right type so
for all of the objects we have in the
model structure we construct a random
variable by subscripting the the tuple
of objects to the function symbol or
predicate symbol and then in any given
possible world Omega this has a value
true or false okay and and then to build
up the whole possible world right we
just imagine sort of simulating the
program in the forward direction we
generate numbers of objects from the
number statements that populates the
world with the objects as we go along
and then we construct all around the
worlds or that sort of the random
variables from all of those objects and
then we give values to all those random
variables and then the world is complete
CPT is fixed the same CPT's being used
so you can have fixed CPT's you can
although pick the CPT entries can also
be random variable so you can do
hierarchical Bayesian models and all the
usual stuff okay and then so that's a
possible world and then the probability
of a world is just as in Bayes nets the
product of all the conditional
probabilities for for generating each
piece of that world as you go along okay
and so this is why we have this slightly
Byzantine construction of the objects
themselves why they're not the usual
featureless tokens of first-order logic
model structures and and we need that
because we want there to be only one way
one path through the program that could
generate that particular possible world
so if you had featureless objects and
you had a particular world with
particular relations holding among
particular objects there could be
combinatorially many paths through the
program by which that particular world
can be constructed and then even to
write down what the probability of that
world is would would involve a difficult
combinatorial exercise in general
vehicle if you have recursive functions
whereas here it's completely
straightforward yeah does this include
adjusting objects or also the values of
the indicator variables the values of
the indicator variables so with a
possible well at the answer to every
question is fixed yeah so it has the
same properties a typical model
structure in logic
right so I said that so then it turns
out that if you make certain
restrictions on the the model that you
write down for example you don't want to
have infinite backward chains because
then there is no there's no route
variable as it were for the for the
network and you don't want to have
cycles so you can't have variables that
that strictly depend on themselves
you need the expression so the the
language includes arbitrary logical
expressions in the in the conditional
sentences so you can have if then some
logical expression if that logical
expression can't be finitely evaluated
than your stock so you can't say you
know if fermat's last theorem is true
then there's a burg you know the
burglary with vulnerability 0.8 right
because the but the the inference engine
won't know it's true and it would be
very hard to write the semantics in such
a way that was that was it was
guaranteed so just as with Turing
machines right there are there are going
to be blog programs that do in fact
define a probability distribution over
all possible worlds but we won't be able
to tell whether they do or not but
there's a subset of the language for
which we can tell in it and this is a
subset there are there are the bigger
subsets that would need more work but
this these are sufficient conditions for
the probability distribution to be
well-defined and these are these are
conditions that we can check ok so I'm
going to give you some examples and then
we'll talk a little bit about inference
okay so here's a nice simple one the
test not the test is a very difficult
morning for you I know it's early
so here are two citations and the
question is are these citations of the
same paper
who thinks yes
who thinks no
and who is uncertain everybody else
right most people are yeah who is people
freon said so yeah it varies sometimes
but between 10 and 90% of people say yes
depending on the audience this was a
mostly AI audience you'd probably
recognize that the National Conference
on AI is the same as what we usually
call triple-a I and so this is probably
the same venue that Cambridge is the
location of MIT press whereas Seattle is
the location of the conference if you
know about Bibb Tech then you can see
that probably it's the same author list
except they put a comma in the bib Tech
author list which then screws up the how
the authors appear when you generate the
latech from the bib Tech and so you'd
say yeah this is almost certainly the
same thing and you know you also know
that that party mass is not likely to be
publishing multiple papers with the same
title and on the whole you think yeah
this is the same paper right but it's
clear this is this is uncertain and this
is absolutely typical these are
relatively benign examples there are
much worse citation strings than this
and this is what Google Scholar and
sites here and all of those engines have
to deal with when they construct the
citation databases that we just take for
granted these days okay so but this is
the core of what those engines are doing
is deciding for any given pair of
citations is this the same paper right
this without that you can't even begin
to begin to build a growth graph of
citations so we're going to take all
this data millions and millions of these
and we have to decide okay what papers
exist what research is eglise what
authors who entreat paper
what is its real title what are the real
authors and what is the citation graph
okay and so I actually started working
on this problem because when sightseer
came out like everyone else I typed in
my name I typed in Russell and Norvig
and which is there is the two authors of
a textbook and so sight see I said that
we'd written 120 books so sites here was
clearly failing at doing this citation
matching problem it had over segmented
they were about at that time 1200
citations the book and it had say
mented them into 120 different books so
there was obviously a problem to be
solved and imagine doing that with
terrorists right so you're wrong by a
factor of a hundred on a number of
terrorists in the United States you know
that either way would be bad
okay so here's if this is a slightly
simplified model for for publications
with a single author and I've left out
part of this which is the the model for
the grammar of citations but this is the
core of of how the model is written
right so we start by saying okay what
exists well there are researchers and
there are papers we don't know how many
researchers we don't know how many
papers and we found that lognormal is a
nice so it's actually a discrete form of
a log normal distribution there's a nice
way of describing numbers about which we
are very uncertain and this basically
says if I remember correctly it's a
hundred thousand plus or minus a factor
of 10 so it's a model you get a
multiplicative standard deviation if you
like because I'm log normal and then the
the number of papers with a given author
so here the the papers are seen as
having the author as the origin function
right so number of papers by a given
author if it's a professor then it's a
hundred plus or minus the factor of ten
otherwise I think this is ten plus or
minus a factor of root ten or something
like that so that describes what we
might expect to see in the domain and
then researchers have names and we have
a basically a prior over strings which
is drawn from the US Census database and
papers have titles and we have a word
trigram combined with a letter trigram
prior which is derived from a whole
database of millions of computer science
papers and then the meat of the model so
this sort basically sets it up is a
declarative part the
well the COBOL people call I think the
days of division and then well then we
have the stuff about citation so Cu
refers to a citation so the publication
cited will assume that when you when you
write a citation you're just choosing a
paper at random to cite okay so it's a
very weak model of how people choose
what to cite
we're just uniformed from the set of
papers okay now you could obviously add
in you know the something about we could
add prominence for papers and again you
wouldn't know a priori of how prominent
any given paper was but you just say
well you know its prominence is between
0 & 1 and that that then goes as a
weight into your choice of which paper
to cite and may be prominence in a
particular field or relevance to the
topic of the paper that you're writing
so you can make these models more and
more sophisticated and they'll they will
perform more and more accurately but
usually in a typical Bayesian way even
if you have very weak priors the data
will sort out a lot of this stuff and
you don't have to be very precise with
the price and then there's this text of
a citation string itself so basically
the citation string again this is a
simplified version of the true model the
citation string is built from the name
of the author of the cited publication
in in this citation and the title of the
cited publication neither of which we
know right we don't know who the author
is we don't know what his name is we
don't know what the title is but
whatever they are the citation string is
built from those take that information
shove it through some kind of noisy
grammar for citations which includes the
ability to introduce spelling mistakes
and punctuation errors all the things
that you actually see in citations and
again it's not a very specific grammar
this this is actually an hmm grammar so
it's much weaker than the grammars that
you could build if you took all the good
text citation types and build grammars
for those and so on okay so that's it
right this is a citation matching system
and so you write that model you supply
the data a bunch of citation strings you
then ask your query right so you have a
you have a full logical query language
you can ask anything you want right
okay you know how many papers are
written by three authors all of whose
name is Blum right you can ask that
there aren't some actually by Manny Blum
Lenora Blum and and every Blum you can
ask all kind any basically anything you
could express in a logical or sql-like
language but these are the basic things
you want what papers exist who wrote
them what's the citation graph okay and
if you if you then put this into the
completely generic inference engine that
here's the problem right you have to
wait a long time because completely
generic inference engines don't know
about how to pause probabilistic
context-free grammars efficiently right
they don't necessarily have the ability
to invent dynamic programming algorithms
on the fly there are all kinds of things
that they're not going to invent that
are the subject of algorithm design for
the last 50 years so a generic inference
engine in general will be slow for most
of these and as we'll see to get it to
work faster you have to develop
efficient proposal distributions for the
MCMC inference okay so you compare this
this is a data from quite a long time
ago when sites here was the best
citation database out there and fight
see it provided some test data sets for
comparison and here the the metric this
is an error metric which is the
percentage of papers for which there is
any error so any error means that you
are missing one of the citations for
that paper or you've added in an extra
citation for that paper that in fact is
not referring to that paper okay so it's
the the strictest possible error for
citation matching and you get these
error rates with site SIA and with the
blog model that I just showed you just
the only real change to it was make it
allow for multiple authors
we cut the error rate by a factor of two
or three and later on with a more
sophisticated model we got it down to
about one percent so which is comparable
to where humans are
because there are a lot of citations
that are just deficient they can tag in
it for example only an author name or
only a title then you can't really
figure out what's going on okay so we
built now quite a large library of
example programs in blog so some typical
machine learning ones PCF G's a ball
alone model which is like species
counting so finding the number of
distinct objects by repeated draws from
a set topic models they're easy to write
all of these are all five or six lines
of blog Auto regression Kalman filters
if interstate hmm and so on there are
some slightly more complex models so
Sybil attack for cybersecurity that's
people who use multiple logins to attack
systems like TripAdvisor or eBay by
generating fraudulent recommendations
and transactions multi target tracking
so let me just show you the multi target
tracking models so the mall target
tracking and data Association is what
you do when you when you have radar and
they they generate blips and then as the
radar goes around you get more blips and
you have to somehow connect up the blips
to each other and form tracks and this
is a whole sub area with with thousands
of journal papers in the electrical
engineering community and and in some
sense this is the this is the sum total
of all that work all right and a nice
thing is that you know so this is a
standard model so aircraft arrive at
random so the number of aircraft you'll
see is a plus on they can leave the
region at any time they stay in flight
in they stay within the visible region
with a certain probability so X is the
state of each aircraft Z is the
observation value for a blip and so this
allows for aircraft appearing and
disappearing it allows for detection
failures it allows for false detection
of non-existent aircraft
so this is a quite sophisticated model
by the standards of the multi target
tracking community but if I want to for
example allow aircraft to follow each
other as opposed to follow independent
tracks which is the standard right I can
do that by changing one or two lines of
the program if I want the aircraft to
take off and land from unknown air bases
I can add that in so aircraft actually
now have a destination and they go
somewhere instead of moving randomly I
can add that in so you can do it lab
eration x' which would be whole PhD
theses worth of work in the traditional
way of doing things you do a whole bunch
of math you do write a whole bunch you
know ten thousand lines of C++ code and
you can do that in one or two lines of
modification to the blog so we actually
even done some vision and we've actually
gone through this exercise with with
online video background subtraction so
this is how you find and track moving
objects in video images and we've shown
that indeed you know you can write two
or three lines a blog to to make the
model more sophisticated and take into
account additional factors about the
about the tracking problem we have a an
extension for yes what's the nature of
the answer your system is giving is it a
sampling approximation
it's a posterior distribution depending
on the algorithm if we're usually using
em TMC so it's a process it's an
approximation to the posterior area
obtained by sampling yeah
and how does that connect the first
segment of your talk which was about
open bubbles as opposed to closed ones
are those models open
so in the multi target tracking for
example if if it's a very noisy radar
then it would say there they may be
three or they may be four aircraft you
know if there are three this is that
these are the tracks if there are four
then those the tracks and that's where
the other one is something from an
actual database is that right no so the
it's good the the evidence supplied to
model just consists of citation strings
okay so literally ASCII strings okay
that's and then the query is what papers
exist say okay there's a paper we'll
call it p1 it has these twelve citations
it has this author and so on so you can
ask relative to the most likely world or
you can ask marginals against the
posterior distribution so there's
different kinds of query interfaces but
think of it as you put in ascii strings
and it gives you a posterior over
citation databases and against that
posterior you can ask any query that you
want
all right so I just want to mention that
there's a decision extension which allow
you to specify actions and utilities and
an engine that can evaluate and modify
policies so we one example is playing
invisible opponent monopoly so you're
playing Monopoly where you don't know
where your opponent's piece is and you
don't know which properties he's bought
the only information you get is that
every so often you receive money or you
have to pay money and you have to figure
out what's going on from there and then
have a policy for you know whether or
not to buy a given property you have to
guess whether your opponent has any of
the other properties in the set based on
all the evidence that you've seen so far
so that's a that's a fun it's
surprisingly capable of playing that
fairly well okay so inference so for all
of those models that we can detect are
provably well-formed block models the
inference algorithms that we've
developed a complete under the usual
caveats about MCMC and other sampling
algorithms being completed that
everything has to be a gothic and so on
so so I think there are a clearly huge
amounts of work to be done on inference
particularly for handling the fact that
in many models there are deterministic
sub models which will mess up MCMC
algorithms and we are working on on some
of those let me just mention some
advantages of using MCMC for this kind
of problem so the mt mt is is wandering
around in the space of partial model
structures
okay partial because we the model
structures are unbounded size for
example we have may have no limit on the
number of houses in a region
Hasaan doesn't have a limit on the
number of houses in the region so so
there are model structures of arbitrary
size but if we don't have any evidence
about those houses we don't have to
instantiate them in the model structures
okay so we can work with partial model
structures and effectively we're then
integrating out all the stuff about
which we have no information and that's
easy to integrate out because it's all
the same so we're wandering around the
space of these partial model structures
it has this has many advantages so
it does not require that any work be
done to calculate any by the user to do
any of the math required to calculate
any of the transition probabilities once
you've written out your blog model the
the blog engine essentially does all the
math to calculate transition
probabilities of appropriately because
it's a sampling algorithm that's just
generating one sample has one sample
state at a time the space requirement is
trivial
the main calculation in in MCMC is to
calculate this acceptance ratio this is
the probability of the new state X
primed this is the probability the old
state X these are the proposal
distributions in both directions and
because the probabilities of the worlds
of products of probabilities for all of
the instantiations of the random
variables and you're only changing one
or a small number of random variables at
a time almost all those probabilities
cancel out so your calculation of this
transition ratio is is entirely local
and usually trivial trivial to carry out
and and also you can incremental
eyes.the the calculation of the query so
you have to evaluate the query on each
state but this is a well-known technique
in database systems that you can
incremental eyes that so as you change
the state by changing the values some of
the random variables you can recalculate
the value of the query without running
the whole query over the whole world
each time so we can make things quite
efficient so you you you pick is
essentially you can you can pick a
random variable which could which could
be one of the variables saying whether
or not a relation holds between some
objects and you can change its truth
value or you can change the number of
variable so you can
you can create or destroy one of the
objects so you can really well regret
and of your program that's going to
decide what exactly and it's usually
those are the moves that create and
delete objects are the ones that usually
cause the MCMC to run slowly because for
example if you if you have a region
that's nicely sitting there with 53
houses and you delete delete that region
then all the houses are going to pick a
new region and they're probably not
going to pick a good one and then you
can have a brain a very bad world which
is unlikely to be accepted by the MCMC
so generically those birth-death or
split merge moves are the ones that
cause you problems
okay I'm gonna in the interest of time
I'm going to skip over the relationship
to probabilistic programming because I
think a lot of people are going to talk
about this during the week I'm just
gonna mention briefly some work that
we've been doing recently on inference
so for the programming language people
in the room this might be completely
obvious but pretty much every
description of a probabilistic inference
algorithm whether it's on Bayes nets or
or the closed universe probability
models or the open universe probability
models describes the model as a data
structure right the Bayes net is a data
structure and then the algorithm
operates on that data structure to do
inference right this is effectively
being an interpreter for that programs I
think it's a big thing of the Bayes net
as a program then operating on that
Bayes net as a structure is running an
interpreter on that program and you get
all of you over head that you get for
interpreting Prolog or interpreting Lisp
or interpreting any other programming
language so what you should be doing
instead is taking the model and then
generating the inference code for that
model specific
because the model itself is not gonna
change while inference is running okay
that gives us a very large piece our
original blog engine was was doing that
it was you know it created an internal
data structure of representation the
model but it was still the data
structure when instead we just generated
code directly which then is running
inference specifically for that model we
got the typical
two orders of magnitude speed-up we
compared it with bugs which is probably
the most widely used Bayes net package
and on the same model for the same
algorithm it runs between seven hundred
and a thousand times faster okay so
we're getting way more expressive power
than bugs because that's strictly a
Bayes net language with the ability to
that's a closed universe Bayes net
language and way more expressive power
and three orders of magnitude more speed
so we can run for example on a laptop at
about a hundred million samples a second
and we're spending most of the CPU time
inside the random number generator so
the the inference overhead is is pretty
small and then there are lots of other
things we can do which I'm not gonna go
into and there's a graph showing the
various speed ups and so the the
compiled blog is down here and then
these in that these are the other
various systems that people have put out
there I want to talk about an
application to nuclear monitoring so the
this is a map of the various locations
where nuclear testing has been done and
this is North Korea which is so every
time I give this talk I have to add
another one to the number of explosions
because North Korea keeps doing it
there there is theoretically a ban which
has not yet gone into force just to give
you a little visual sense of what a
nuclear test looks like this is this
this is the crater from a very small
nuclear test this test was one five
hundredth of the size of the largest
test that was ever done and in it they
make quite a big bang
so the treaty was proposed in 58 banning
nuclear testing and it was signed I was
open for signature in the UN and 96
almost all countries in the world have
signed it it's a very tough treaty
because if there's evidence that you
have been testing you essentially agree
to allow yourself to be invaded and a
thousand square kilometers can be
occupied and inspected unfortunately the
US hasn't ratified it so that means the
treaty hasn't gone into force but the
u.s. is at least honoring the treaty and
the UN has built a network with 278
monitoring stations around the world
seismic is the most useful evidence we
don't expect people to be doing air
testing it's all underground
so seismic is the main source of
evidence for testing occurring so you
familiar with what a seismogram looks
like this is a typical this is a
magnitude 6 earthquake so on this scale
a nuclear test might look like that
little bump over there and so it's not
easy to find nuclear test particularly
because there's a massive amount of
background noise so the goal of the
monitoring system is we have all these
marching stations collecting data in
real time what we need is to output a
Daily Bulletin as it turns out these are
all the events that took place of any
you know any reasonable magnitude okay
and running running late where do they
take place how deep were they how large
were they and then usually the nuclear
explosions will be fairly easy to sort
out from that list and it's a hard
problem because there's a massive amount
of of noise and so the UN has spent a
lot of money over a billion dollars
building this detection monitoring
sunette work and all the software and
yet they're only able to detect about
69% of the events that they'll be
interested in and then they have a whole
bunch of human experts who are then
sifting over
what's left and trying to figure out all
the other events and in the whole system
including the humans is still not very
good for for low magnitude events as I
said there's a lot of background noise
the the geophysics of the world is quite
complicated because every event produces
dozens of wave types with different
velocities and it takes hours for those
wave types to propagate around the world
and so it's like having thousands of
conversations or garbled and mixed
together and then arriving at hundreds
of different microphones ok so here's
how it works right there's a bunch of
detection stations an event takes place
seismic signals propagate from the event
they reach the station they cause blips
so here two blips arrived at the station
at the bottom then another event blue
one and then some blue blips arrive at
the top station notice that the blue and
the red blips switched in in time
sequence because of different locations
and then at the end you have a bunch of
blips
at a bunch of stations and of course
they're not colored right we don't know
where those blips came from and so we
have uncertainty about what events exist
and about which blips are associated
with which events so it's a typical open
universe probabilistic inference problem
so we wrote a blog model that's the blog
model that I wrote it describes all the
geophysics that I just said allows for
uncertainty and propagation time and
detection and all the rest of it
includes a model of noise I'm going to
skip over it this is a picture of part
of the prior four location of natural
seismic events this is the probability
detection as a function of magnitude and
distance from the event this is the
uncertainty about the travel time
prediction how long does it take to get
to a given station from a given source
and so on we ran it on a bunch of data
which the UN gave us for a three-month
period this is the the fraction of
events missed so in the existing UN
system between 30 and 50 percent
depending on magnitude are missed and
the the Bayesian model the blog program
just running on the
supplied from the seismic stations has
about a 11 to 12 percent failure rate so
is effectively about a 1 magnitude
reduction in the in the sensitive level
sensitivity level of the system from
exactly the same data in this was a
couple of years of one graduate student
basically getting the inference to run
fast enough to make it real time so I
think that the evidence shows that these
kinds of languages can do very useful
work and do it better than traditional
and software construction techniques
just this is a little piece of data from
the test three years ago in North Korea
so this is where we think the event took
place from satellite photographs that's
the tunnel entrance to the underground
testing this is the best guess of the UN
as well as the USGS and all of their
human experts as from all the seismic
data and then this is the location
estimate from our system as to where we
think it is with the uncertainty come to
our show okay so I think this system
will be the the new monitoring system
for the treaty according to the UN and
just to sum up there's there's a lot of
stuff real work still to do I think
inference is the primary task here I
think from the point of view of
representation power for the
applications we tried it seems to work
you know if you have enough of a clue
about what is the causal structure the
domain that you're looking at then you
can express it pretty well with this
language and with some of the other
probabilistic programming languages that
we looked at and for all of these
languages making inference sufficiently
fast to be practical so for the seismic
case we spent a long time working on
proposal distributions to make it mix
quickly
most the time wind okay and so one of
the things we're looking at now in
particular is natural language
understanding as I mentioned we know
with natural language understand you
have the same problems you don't know
what objects you're going to be reading
about you don't know how they're going
to be referred to or they're gonna be
referred to as mr. president or mr.
Obama or Barack Obama or the President
or any there are many many ways you can
refer to objects and events we also
allow for uncertainty about even what
words mean or what relations exist so
you can have uncertainty over the
relations that exist and then the system
can figure out from text what relations
exist and how they're expressed in text
so you can do completely unsupervised
natural language understanding these
techniques okay thank you very much
French funders so I was on sabbatical in
Paris for two years and so I had a I now
she had excellence and then you know the
France funds the share Blaise Pascal so
you have this generic syntax and it's
very expressive and then for each I mean
I say no it's eternal right what I
understand is that for each specific
model you're building you're going to
design a new strategy to infer and then
it's incredibly more efficient than
generic strategies that's right yeah so
some some applications so we did we did
one the video background subtraction so
we have a generic inference algorithm
for temporal models which does a kind of
particle filtering that's a completely
another like MCMC completely generic and
that was that's now with the compiler
fast enough to do real-time video
processing and we didn't have to write
any special proposal distribution for
that
so on some applications the generic
stuff is now fast enough but on others
yeah particularly as I said where you
need to do split merge or birth death
proposals to figure out what objects
exist how can you be so much more
efficient and people were solving
specific problems even though they don't
have the same level of generic
expressivity you just like this is
something intuitive I understand here so
wait so you're talking about the
comparison with bugs free generic
strategy for compiling and that you're
better than people are just doing this
no I think I just said it runs in real
time there are plenty of other vision
algorithms that run in real time yeah
you can